[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
irlanda es uno de los países más ricos
del mundo pero eso ya lo sabéis
prácticamente todas las grandes
tecnológicas desde apple hasta google
tienen su sede europea en irlanda es más
si trabajas en algo relacionado con y te
seguro que alguna vez te habrá llegado
alguna oferta para trabajar en dublín
huenchor lo que probablemente no sepáis
es que es realmente rico quiero decir es
más rico incluso que suiza pero no sólo
eso irlanda lleva más de una década
creciendo a ritmos de país emergente os
acordáis del año 2020 si ese año el del
coronavirus ese año en el que
prácticamente todos los países del mundo
entraron en recesión pues bien irlanda
no sólo siguió creciendo sino que su pib
creció al 5,8 por ciento para que os
hagáis una idea estas son cifras propias
de un país como china o vietnam
todo esto es sorprendente sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que muchos economistas
llevan años prediciendo un supuesto
colapso económico en irlanda entre ellos
está el premio nobel de economía paul
krugman sin embargo en estos momentos el
salario medio de irlanda está en los 44
mil 200 dólares anuales y en el año 2015
irlanda rompió todos los récords
imaginables cuando crecieron al
25% si habéis oído bien 25% de
crecimiento del pib vale este número
tiene trampa pero hablaremos de eso más
adelante la pregunta es por qué que hace
que irlanda sea tan increíblemente
próspera
[Música]
seguramente muchos ya tengáis una
respuesta en la cabeza impuestos bajos
exacto irlanda tiene lo de los impuestos
de sociedades más bajos del mundo esto
ha servido para atraer a las mayores
multinacionales del planeta sin embargo
atentos a esta noticia
una república de irlanda subirá su
impuesto de sociedades al 15% y la
pregunta es ahora que van a subir el
impuesto de sociedades se acabó la
gallina de los huevos de oro
irlanda es mucho más que simplemente un
país con impuestos bajos porque irlanda
es tan rico y porque siguen creciendo
como si fueran un país emergente hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
disciplina tubos ton
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
especialmente los que veáis este vídeo
desde los eeuu lo primero que os viene a
la cabeza cuando pensáis en irlanda es
el desfile de san patricio en boston
este desfile que ya se ha hecho famoso
por el tradicional concierto de los
dropkick murphys y si habéis oído bien
el dicho boston massachusetts en eeuu y
no he hablado de dublín porque lo cierto
es que hay más descendientes de
irlandeses viviendo en eeuu que en la
propia irlanda atentos a esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver como irlanda ha estado
perdiendo población desde el siglo 19 es
decir desde antes incluso de
independizarse de reino unido- y esto
tiene una explicación pobreza durante
siglos la isla de irlanda era parte del
reino unido- pero eran pobres de
solemnidad los irlandeses eran
claramente ciudadanos de segunda y no
creáis que hablamos de la típica pobreza
de dentro del primer mundo no hablamos
de auténtica miseria para que os hagáis
una idea sólo en los años 40 del siglo
19 más de un millón de irlandeses
murieron de hambre sin embargo en el año
1937 y tras una cruenta guerra civil la
república de irlanda redactó su
constitución sin embargo la pobreza y el
hambre y persistieron porque la
respuesta está en la política
i
tras independizarse irlanda apostó por
un modelo económico basado en la
autosuficiencia pensadlo bien eeuu
todavía estaba recuperándose del crack
del 29 el libre mercado no estaba
precisamente de moda así que irlanda
quería conseguir la independencia
económica y no querían importar nada del
exterior conclusión pues ya os lo podéis
imaginar el proteccionismo rara vez
funciona pero es que si hay un país
donde es aún más difícil que funcione
ese era precisamente irlanda pensar que
hablamos de una isla con menos de 4
millones de habitantes que a duras penas
estaba industrializada como os podéis
imaginar es difícil que una economía tan
pequeña pueda llegar a ser
autosuficiente así que ante la falta de
importaciones irlanda sigue liderando la
exportación de una cosa irlandeses eso
explica que algunas ciudades americanas
como boston tengan una conexión tan
fuerte con irlanda
sin embargo las cosas empezaron a
cambiar en el año 1959 con este señor
que veis en pantalla son tomás ok esta
señora era el primer ministro de irlanda
y es el padre del primer intento de
liberalizar la economía irlandesa y
diréis porque digo intento de pues
porque el bueno de hotel y sólo aplicó
algunas partes de la receta en el año
1959 creó una zona de libre comercio al
lado del aeropuerto de saná así es como
llegaron las primeras empresas
extranjeras durante las décadas
posteriores irlanda redujo los impuestos
a empresas para atraer aún más
corporaciones por ejemplo apple se
estableció en irlanda en el año 1980 sin
embargo nada de esto sirvió para que los
irlandeses vivieran mejor más bien todo
lo contrario por un lado las empresas
extranjeras se limitaban a establecer
sus sedes fiscales nada más es decir que
las primeras oficinas de apeló de
hewlett packard tenían sólo unos pocos
contables en plantilla pero no sólo eso
por aquellos años irlanda apenas tenía
industria sus empresas estaban ancladas
en el siglo 19 así que al permitir las
importaciones de productos extranjeros
reventaban el mercado conclusión en el
año 1987 cuando irlanda tenía un paro
del 17 por ciento los sueldos eran una
tercera parte de su equivalente en reino
unido e irlanda volvía a liderar una
exportación e irlandeses dicho de otra
forma por mucho que irlanda bajará su
impuesto de sociedades- el país seguía
siendo pobre y la pregunta es entonces
cómo ha llegado irlanda a ser el 'tigre
celta' que conocemos hoy en día pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
rugido del 'tigre celta'
la pregunta la gran pregunta de la
irlanda de los años 80 era que hace
falta para que las multinacionales
contraten irlandeses vale ok os estamos
poniendo la alfombra roja para que
montes oficinas en nuestro país pero
queremos oficinas de verdad no solo una
sede fiscal pues bien esa es la pregunta
que se hizo el señor charles haqqni que
era el primer ministro de irlanda en
1987 este buen señor y su equipo se
dieron cuenta de una cosa sí es cierto
irlanda tenía impuestos bajos para
empresas pero todo lo demás era un
auténtico caos los trabajadores tenían
que pagar hasta un 60 por ciento de
impuestos de la renta y la legislación
laboral era tan estricta que contratar y
despedir se convertía en un auténtico
viacrucis burocrático conclusión hackney
hizo la auténtica liberalización que
irlanda necesitaba y los resultados no
se hicieron esperar una planta de hp en
la isla para 2000 trabajos para el año
2000 de repente los medios irlandeses
empezaron a publicar noticias como ésta
casi todos los meses para que os hagáis
una idea en poco más de una década los
irlandeses pasaron de cobrar dos
terceras partes de lo que cobraban sus
vecinos ingleses
le superan
[Música]
eran los años del tigre celta el país
estaba on fire pero esperad un momento
porque no sólo hablamos de
multinacionales por estos años surgieron
un montón de gigantes irlandés eso suena
prime art pues suena a ryanair pues todo
esto son empresas que nacieron o que
empezaron a expandirse por estos años
para que os hagáis una idea hablamos de
una época tan próspera que incluso se
llegó a poner de moda celebrar bodas y
bautizos desde un helicóptero los bancos
daban hipotecas a diestro y siniestro y
los irlandeses se acostumbraron
demasiado pronto a vivir demasiado bien
muy bien dicho de otra forma que irlanda
era algo así como el sueño húmedo de
cualquier liberal la prueba de que el
libre mercado y el capitalismo funciona
de forma casi milagrosa sin embargo la
alegría duró solamente unos años atentos
efecto dominó
podríamos decir que irlanda es el puente
que une eeuu con europa y esto significa
que los bancos irlandeses estaban
demasiado expuestos a los bancos
estadounidenses eso explica que la gran
crisis financiera del año 2008 golpeará
especialmente irlanda atentos a esta
gráfica
[Música]
aquí podéis ver como irlanda sufrió una
recesión incluso peor que eeuu y ya os
podéis imaginar la cantidad de
economistas y analistas que por aquellos
años entonaban él te lo dije pero eso no
es todo que creéis que hizo irlanda para
evitar el colapso de sus bancos
exacto pedir un rescate
[Música]
tanto la unión europea como el fondo
monetario internacional rescataron
irlanda con un préstamo de 67 mil 500
millones de euros para que os hagáis una
idea esto es un 40 por ciento de todo el
pib del país y diréis como quería
devolver irlanda todo ese dinero exacto
con medidas de austeridad dicho de otra
forma irlanda subió algunos impuestos
indirectos y recortó el gasto público en
todos los frentes bajaron los sueldos a
los funcionarios en un 14 por ciento
cerraron hasta 41 agencias del gobierno
y como os podéis imaginar todo esto
desató las mayores protestas de la
irlanda moderna y ahí es cuando los
economistas como paul krugman volvieron
a entonar el te lo dije a atentos
irlanda hasta ahora en su tercer año de
austeridad y la confianza sigue cayendo
me veréis preguntaros que hace falta
para que la gente sería se dé cuenta de
que castigar a la población por los
pecados de sus banqueros y es peor que
un crimen es un error el krugman en the
new york times' quedaos con esta cita
desde un artículo escrito en el año 2010
pues bien dos años más tarde el tiempo
decidió contradecir al bueno de paul
krugman atentos
[Música]
como podéis ver irlanda no solo se ha
recuperado de la crisis es que ahora
mismo es sustancialmente más rico que el
propio eeuu y si fijaos bien en el salto
que da entre 2014 y 2016 esa es la fecha
en la que irlanda batió todos los
récords y llego a crecer hasta un 25 por
ciento de su pib la pregunta es cómo lo
hicieron hay algo de trampa ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
cuando el pib no es suficiente
imaginaos la cara del bueno de paul
krugman pero dijo el colapso económico
de irlanda un auster incidió que nunca
llegó en pocos años irlanda dejó de lado
la crisis de deuda y volvió a crecer
como si no hubiera mañana no sólo a
crecer es que incluso llegó a batir
todos los récords de la historia
económica una tasa del crecimiento del
25 por ciento boom sorry not sorry china
así que qué creéis que hizo el bueno de
paul krugman puedes ponerse investigar
la auténtica razón de ese crecimiento
tan espectacular atentos la economía del
epre count irlanda reporta un 26 por
ciento de crecimiento esto no tiene
sentido porque está esto en el pib paul
krugman y lo cierto es que en este caso
cruz mantenía toda la razón del mundo
esa subida del más del 25 por ciento del
pib se debe a que las grandes
multinacionales principalmente apple
movieron sus beneficios a irlanda para
beneficiarse de esos impuestos tan bajos
para que os hagáis una idea solamente
apple llegó a mover más de 147 mil
millones de euros e irlanda entre 2004 y
2014 se trata de una simple operación
financiera pero 147 mil millones de
euros es una auténtica salvajada de
dinero sobre todo para un país pequeño
irlanda con un pib ahora en 2022 está en
los 400 18.000 millones de euros dicho
de otra forma la estadística no refleja
la realidad todo ese dinero de apple no
ha llegado de verdad a la economía
irlandesa en realidad es sólo un número
en un balance y lo cierto es que apple
no son los únicos
según el fm y el 60% de la inversión
extranjera en irlanda son simples
números a todo esto krugman lo llamo le
pre con economía luego lo pre con son
unos duendes de la mitología irlandesa
dicho de otra forma que la econometría
clásica simplemente no funciona en
irlanda las distorsiones estadísticas
creadas por el impacto de los activos
globales y las actividades de las
multinacionales en las cuentas
nacionales irlandesas se han vuelto tan
grandes que el pib irlandés saura una
broma patrick honohan es gobernador del
banco central de irlanda de hecho a día
de hoy irlanda utiliza unas magnitudes
distintas que el resto de países para
medir su economía y diréis cuáles son
esas magnitudes como se mide el pib pues
este tipo de preguntas no son propias de
visual polític pero si tienen cabida en
visual económico por si no lo sabéis
tenemos un canal hermano donde hablamos
en profundidad de nuestra otra gran
pasión la economía nos interesa en este
tipo de cuestiones os esperamos por ahí
pero volvamos ahora con nuestra historia
de hoy porque distorsiones estadísticas
aparte el fenómeno de las le pré con
economics sirvió para poner en el centro
del debate todos esos esquemas fiscales
de irlanda
montones de multinacionales han estado
aprovechando los impuestos bajos de
irlanda para crear toda clase de
esquemas fiscales con los que pagar muy
pocos impuestos de hecho para el año
2017 tanto la unión europea como eeuu ya
han sacado varias medidas para evitar la
competencia fiscal de irlanda pero no
sólo eso el propio gobierno de irlanda
ya se ha comprometido a subir los
impuestos a atentos la república de
irlanda subirá su impuesto de sociedades
al 15% y la pregunta es hasta qué punto
paul krugman tiene razón es decir si la
riqueza de irlanda se debe simplemente a
trampas contables y tributación baja
estamos ante el fin del milagro irlandés
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
ireland
vamos a decirlo claro el éxito de
irlanda no consiste en atraer a grandes
empresas con impuestos bajos y la
prosperidad fuera tan simple como bajar
impuestos andorra sería un país de
millonarios y liberia no sería tan pobre
el auténtico éxito de irlanda consiste
en haber logrado que esas empresas se
establezcan de verdad en el país y
contratan gente no sólo eso irlanda ha
conseguido que surjan en el propio país
empresas propias que ya son gigantes por
ejemplo o suena ryanair se trata del
gigante de los vuelos low cost seguro
que si vivís en europa algún día habréis
volado con esta empresa se trata de una
de las empresas más disruptivas de la
historia pero lo cierto es que ryanair
sólo es la punta del iceberg de una
industria muchísimo más grande puede que
os sorprenda pero irlanda es la potencia
mundial en aerolíneas tal cual como lo
oís quedaros con estos nombres air cab
ib y capital aviation services o a bolón
seguramente nunca hayáis oído hablar de
estas empresas verdad pues bien son los
titanes del alquiler de aviones
comerciales
[Música]
veréis la mayor parte de las aerolíneas
comerciales del mundo no tienen sus
propios aviones los alquilan pues bien
el 22 por ciento de los aviones
comerciales que vuelan en el mundo
vienen de empresas irlandesas como os
quedáis hablamos de una industria que ha
llegado a dar más de 4 mil puestos de
trabajo y que me decís del software
cierto este es el sector donde están
todas esas grandes multinacionales desde
google hasta facebook todas ellas tienen
su sede fiscal en irlanda pero no sólo
hablamos de sedes fiscales sólo el
sector del software da trabajo a 24.000
personas todo esto está muy bien si
tenemos en cuenta que la población de
irlanda no llega a los 5 millones de
habitantes en otras palabras que la
economía de irlanda no sólo está hiper
diversificada además está llena de
líderes mundiales y todo esto explica
que ni siquiera el coronavirus haya
hecho mella en el país dicho de otra
forma no parece que irlanda esté al
borde de ninguna crisis importante al
menos no el tipo de crisis que se
imaginaría el bono de paul krugman
significa esto que los irlandeses no
tienen ningún problema no exactamente
pero hablamos de otro tipo de problemas
atentos
la crisis de la vivienda decidirá el
futuro político de irlanda exacto esta
es la cara beit del éxito económico
irlanda ya no exporta mano de obra todo
lo contrario ciudades como dublín o core
que están recibiendo gente de todas
partes y apenas hay casas para hospedar
a tantas personas no hablamos de un
problema menor y además se trata de algo
que afecta a muchos otros países pero
irlanda tiene un problema especialmente
acuciante en este sentido la pregunta
ahora es cómo se puede solucionar y lo
que es más importante qué lecciones se
pueden sacar del modelo y grandes para
otros países como creéis que el afectará
a irlanda la crisis provocada por la
guerra de ucrania podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios
y recordad visitar nuestro canal visual
económico donde hablamos en profundidad
de todos estos temas tan fascinantes que
bueno pues en nuestra otra gran pasión
la economía y por supuesto no olvidéis
que aquí en visual polític sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a este canal y dada la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si se gusto de
este vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]